[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be talking about
building a better society we have Matt
Pruett joining us on the show hello
hello thanks so much for coming on Matt
thank you for having me very excited for
this episode those who don't know Matt's
background Matt Pruitt is president at
radical exchange foundation which uses
mechanism design to improve basic
institutions find the links in the Bible
o2 radical exchange org
as well as the Twitter for rad exchange
and Matt's Twitter as well alright let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions to us ask our guests
what are your thoughts in the direction
of our world that's like a big question
my I think that I'm basically agnostic
so something I often resist the
temptation to say that I'm optimistic or
pessimistic because the reality is I
don't know I'm cautiously optimistic I
want to do what I everything I can to
make sure the future looks great and I
think we you know anything can happen
and it's our job to make sure that we
make it as good as we can and what would
you say are some of the key things that
we need to embody moving forward to make
it as optimistic positive as we can I
think we need to be very thoughtful I
think we need to try to foresee the
consequences of our actions as
scrupulous ly as we can and kind of
accept that that responsibility I think
we need to you know look beyond our own
our own interests but also be realistic
about the fact that are our own and you
know for self interest motivates people
and you know do our best
that's good yeah that Nash equilibrium
between one's own self interests and the
collective interests and then also like
the 7 generation rule of indigenous
people like thinking 7 generations out
of our actions yeah yeah that's a great
idea yeah it should be more of that I
love it I love it alright let's break
down the journey so born in Oakland and
then you went to brown and then the
University Michigan for law school but
teach us about who you were as a kid and
how you even got interested in some of
these concepts that we're talking about
today who I was as a kid I think I was a
kind of a thoughtful occasionally you
know in you know introverted kid I've
always had a really wide range of
interests I think that if you'd talk to
me and in in middle school or high
school I would have said I want to be a
writer or philosopher or something like
that and you know got a little
sidetracked along the way but ultimately
that's where that's where like my that's
where the heat is with me and that's
that's what I'm interested in you know
but I I mean my background is like
fairly middle-class suburban
you know nothing nothing out of the
ordinary but I feel you know fortunate
to have had a you know gotten a great
education and had a parents who helped
bring me along well so you know a lot of
advantages yeah took the leap out to
brown yep yep and then the law school at
background as well learning that how did
that end up coming up that you ended up
getting interested in law pursuing that
I was definitely the I was definitely
the classic like you know people say
that not knowing what you want to do is
the wrong reason to go to law school I
was exactly that you know the I knew
that I was I knew that I could write I
knew that I could make arguments for
things and I knew that I enjoyed doing
that but I was actually never truly
attracted to the role of being a lawyer
like I never I didn't really want that
career I just knew that that's kind of
where my where my skill set was and and
and I think that combined with the fact
that lawyers get to engage these basic
questions of like justice and and you
know how to structure society yeah it
was enough to like pull me into it
you know but then once like once I got
into law school I had to find my way
I've had to find my way through like the
career track of being a lawyer back to
things that interested me be more fully
if that makes sense
yeah totally it's good that you got that
background training with justice and
figuring out how to structure society
optimally because that totally leads us
yeah and to rattle what a radical change
is doing and what you're passionate
about now right yeah but we have to talk
about this when you're practicing law in
New York you worked for the federal
judge in New York
what is that like is that like these
these circuit courts that are right
below the Supreme some art I work for a
district court judge a district is below
the circuit court just below the circuit
court god okay and but what you know
district courts are our trial courts you
know so they you actually your feet are
closer to the ground and you actually
kind of see the gears of justice working
more intimately like if you just if you
work at a circuit court at the Supreme
Court all you get are these like highly
abstract edge cases mmm you know you
don't see you know you don't see like
the sorts of everyday criminal and civil
disputes that arise so what are the most
like yeah common criminal and civil
disputes that arise well it depends on
like what court you know so in New York
you get a lot of financial you know
finance industry type stuff and on
particularly on the civil side and on I
guess on the criminal side too and you
see like money laundering and those
kinds of cases but then you also get you
know just like drug cases and you know
violent crime and and the the kinds of
criminal cases that the judges see
everywhere yeah and then what was that
like for you like what were you feeling
when you were doing this I actually felt
so I I felt it was a real privilege to
be in a position to to try to help a
judge get to the best outcome you know
to get to the most just outcome like
being a clerking for a judge is one of
those kind of behind the scenes
positions of power that not everybody's
you know totally aware of what clerks
are
but they they have their in a position
of great influence and going through
that canned kind of you know put some
hair on your chin so to speak like you
have to you have to you know be willing
to think about real things happening to
real people in in a really serious way
so yeah I it was in their families yeah
right yeah and it's heart that it's
heart so hard yeah yeah yeah just you
know rushing to imprison people is can
be it's really really tough thing and
impacts people their families yeah right
but also holding yeah justice for acts
of violence or murder or rape or yeah
try drug trafficking money laundering
there's all different types of waste
stuff to uphold a structured society
that yeah right hard yeah and I mean we
you know it's not a secret that the
United States has a fairly dysfunctional
criminal justice system
yeah and when you're working for a court
in a way you're participating in it but
then you're also in a position to try to
mitigate the problems with it
yeah and I certainly tried to do that
yeah
yeah updating the the Society's code to
have more just for criminal justice I
think that's massive and I think we're
slowly moving in that direction I think
even back to the ideas of the founding
fathers and all the amendments that
we've had to the Constitution that we
weren't expecting exponential technology
in these complex geopolitical landscapes
and having over 600,000 people be
represented by a single person in
Congress right so these are all things
that need to be yea updated right with
the scale of our society is one of the
biggest things that just like group
there was no way to first see that I
mean there was no way or even if you
could have foreseen it how could you
plan for it it's it just changes the
dynamics and everything so to not be
like too slow and too conservative but
to not be too liberal either but to be
kind of like just right with the amount
of changes that need to be made to a
society's code that make it easy to deal
easier to deal with the scale that we're
going through yeah exactly like you want
to like you want institutions need to
need to evolve but then they they also
need to maintain certain continuity with
the past because it you know and that
continuity kind of happens in my bidding
and on the layer of principles yes yes
like they're certain there are certain
principles have been around really long
time yeah they're they're quite valuable
but we don't want to lose free speech
exactly but we need to continue to
reinterpret those principles in light of
varying you know new set of facts
censorship on tech platforms all this
type of stuff yeah yeah
yeah
I like that the first principles
perspective yeah let's let's do some of
the stuff you were dealing with an
antitrust and consumer class action what
is that so
so before I clerked I worked for a large
firm on the defense side as it's just a
civil litigator
which was a great experience I loved
everybody who worked with and I had a
you know learned a ton but I I think
actually and this is you know we can
develop this as we talk about my work on
the plaintiff side but I didn't I didn't
actually like the role of being an
advocate that much and here's why
because I learned through being a
litigator that what I liked about
arguing what I liked about writing and
constructing arguments was the aspect of
that that I really enjoyed the most was
trying to figure out what I thought was
was true and when you're in the position
of an advocate that's not exactly what
you're doing you know you you're you're
you're trying to figure out you're
working as hard as you can to try to
figure out the best possible argument
for your client which is you know a
viable thing to do and somebody's got to
do it but it's not honestly what I most
enjoyed about you know lawyering and so
when I was on the defense side I often
felt like you know you know I didn't
always feel like I you know in it I
didn't always feel I was on the right
side it's one way of putting it right
ooh
hard envious wasn't your ethos wasn't
aligning necessarily with who how you
were needing to represent right the best
case for the person you were
representing right and and but this can
get this can get super complicated
because have are I could we could just
talk about lawyering this whole time
honestly yes
yeah the the thing is like even when you
believe in the in your client even when
you believe your client is right
sometimes you have to make arguments
that you may not think are right in
order to zealously represent your client
yeah who is over all right right and
this can be hard damn right yeah
so then you your bit you're you're
figuring out how to structure your own
your own way of being persuasive that
that is in a way that you that maybe
that doesn't follow maybe some of your
morals or ethics but that overall is
representing the person that you think
should be winning and so that's yeah
right yeah so you know so you have like
you know there are different ways I
think people deal with this in different
ways some people I think some people
really feel the need to be kind of you
know body mind and spirit aligned with
their client right and and so and and
there are different ways of doing that
one way is to like just pick your
clients right only represent clients
that you fully 1,000% believe in yeah
which is actually impossible if you
think about it and the and the other
another way of doing it is to is to just
sort of embody the role of the Advocate
right embody the role of the lawyer and
in order to do that you have to like
fully believe in the system you have to
believe that that by by filling the
advocates role to the best of your
abilities you are contributing to the
system that overall works out for the
best which is also something sometimes
difficult it's this may not stand up to
scrutiny so so I mean I struggled with
this I think a lot of lawyers struggle
with it people find their own ways of
threading that needle and but I guess
long story short is that after some time
on the defense side I was interested in
representing the other sides and
interested in representing you know
smaller parties like you know not big
corporations and stuff and
and I did that for for a few you know
couple years I guess as a antitrust and
consumer class-action litigator and what
is that well you know class actions are
the I mean the gist of class actions are
you know that you represent you
represent a class so a group of people
who've all been harmed in a similar way
right and this is like a mechanism
that's a little bit peculiar to the
American legal system that allows people
to like group their claims in this way
and the you know the basic idea is that
it is it creates efficiencies because if
you've got lots of people harmed in
essentially the same way it's more
efficient for them to be able to group
their claims like if a company was
thrown justly let go like a hundred or
five hundred people or something like
that yeah exactly although that would be
so that's a good example because that
would be like a hard class to bring
actually because you know the the
company would be able to say oh but all
these five hundred people are in subtly
different situations right see we can't
litigate this as a class we can't live
this isn't one question this is 500
questions so the role the job of a
class-action lawyers is to make the
argument that this isn't 500 questions
this isn't a million questions this is
one question this is a million people
who all basically suffered the same kind
of harm which was right attentionally at
the company yeah it's something happened
to its finances or whatever that had
needed to release the 500 people right
so that would be you know that would be
like an employment situation but then an
antitrust situation it would be you know
that there was a like let's say that
there was antitrust conspiracy which
caused prices to go up and thousands of
people paid paid you know prices that
are too high because they you know they
all suffered from the same harm the same
antitrust violation so in so antitrust
is
mostly visible in kind of the kind of
the dynamics that occur between in many
ways like oligopolies yeah or monopolies
I mean like the you know the classic in
case you know instances of antitrust law
have to do with with monopolies and are
they trying to like do things like build
moats or bridges around their projects
and fortunes so that way it's harder for
other people to come in and so then
that's maybe they're trying to sue the
company for doing things that make it
harder for smaller medium-sized
companies to try and come in to
marketplaces yeah then you know just
suppressing competition
maybe something like on like Amazon Web
Services or or even just Amazon
Marketplace themselves just making it
more and more their algorithms showing
up their products more and more often
than the smaller medium-sized businesses
that are trying to market yeah I mean
the this is the right ballpark like this
is the kind of thing that like antitrust
litigation
you know antitrust litigators worry
about but the truth is that you know
it's really hard to bring like a
monopolization case now because you know
yeah
the it's hard to show that consumers are
being harmed by Amazon you know there's
you know it's it's always easy to sort
of make the argument that like no matter
how big Amazon is you know somebody else
is gonna come along and create an
e-commerce site like Amazon isn't
preventing anybody from doing that so
it's hard and and and for various kind
of more technical reasons like the the
doctrine has evolved over the years and
it's just become quite hard to you know
to convince a court that there's a
monopoly problem so the kinds of
antitrust cases that that tend to be
successful in court these days have
tend to be in the area of like
price-fixing like antitrust conspiracies
so you know if you've got if you've got
you know five or six players in the
market and they're like agreeing yeah
not to compete on prices right yeah so
those are the kinds of those are the
kinds of cases that plaintiff side
antitrust lawyers can actually win
because you know there might be like
emails sent up and we agree now for our
prices you know so that those are like
this sort of winnable antitrust cases
these days from a plaintiff's
perspective but obviously there's there
the the problems out there in the
marketplace that make competition
imperfect or a lot broader than that
yeah and that's actually like one of the
one of the things that is a little
frustrating a little disillusioning
about practicing antitrust law from the
plaintiffs point of view because it's
like a lot of the a lot of things that
you're really worried about like there
isn't there isn't actually a winnable
legal case there you know and sometimes
the things that you might that you know
you're honestly a little less worried
about are the winnable cases which is
like another kind of frustrating
misalignment does that make sense yeah
yeah we could do a whole episode plus on
just the differences in antitrust and
also on how to best update the code of
our judicial systems in general yeah
yeah so it I love I love where where the
conversation has taken us in the first
bit let's let's move sure okay let's do
so then you started working in a
blockchain programming mechanism design
that's when you also started working
with Glenn on radical exchange yeah and
then you ended up moving back to the bay
we have a couple assets that we'll be
showing on these separate little three
sort of points that we're going to be
hitting on yeah what was that time like
getting involved with radical exchange
learning about mechanism design so I've
been like a hobbyist programmer for many
years and I got really interested in
blockchain a few years ago
just thinking about basically thinking
about how to use it to solve various
kinds of collective action problems yeah
and you know towards the towards the end
of my time as a litigator I found myself
I found myself thinking about that a lot
and I eventually decided to take a bit
of a leap of faith and you know try to
switch fields and work on that problem
and so through that I started kind of
programming and trying to build tools
basically like you know aetherium based
smart contract tools that could allow
[Music]
interesting forms of collaboration and
collective act you know collective
action problem solving and through that
work got interested in this problem of
mechanism design right and Glenn while
is you know I work with the radical
exchange has done really amazing work in
that in that area so I found his work
started reading about it got in touch
with Glenn and started you know put
together this little group radical
exchange foundation and you know put on
a conference in Detroit March so yeah
it's a yeah that's good yeah yeah and
the mechanisms themselves on beam to
leverage things like blockchain for
collective action I think it's a very
fascinating field and will be I think
that edge is being pushed right now
collective action leveraging
decentralized Ledger's I think is really
interesting and then ok let's start
unpacking the different fields that are
being pushed by radical exchange trying
to build a better society yeah one of
them is voting and you're teaching me
about the concept of quadratic voting I
thought this was really interesting ok
so this is a this is a kind of a
illustration of how quadratic voting
but maybe I should start by just
explaining it in words the the the basic
idea and quadratic voting is that
instead of instead of one person getting
one vote on every issue the way like
normal voting works every person gets a
budget of what you call them like voice
credits okay voice credits yeah are you
voting the credit whatever you want
captain right you got you know yeah
chips chips engines and you can put your
voice credits you can allocate your
voice credits across different voting
issues however you want I can put all of
them in one or I could put them little
bits into a bunch of different ones
exactly so you could you could spread
them out in which case it's just exactly
the same as everybody getting one vote
on each issue mm-hmm or you could
concentrate them all on the issue on one
issue that you care about to the
exclusion of all other issues and here's
the catch if you do that the catch is
that if you if you concentrate your
credits on one issue then you get a less
voice overall yeah okay and it's and
it's not just that you don't get to vote
on the other issues because you
concentrated all your voting credits on
one issue it's actually that you get you
get less voice period because so the so
here's that works like if you if like
let's say I wanted to vote twice on one
issue did I let's so so let's say you've
got nine total credits right yeah this
is token this is ten oh those ten
credits okay so imagine this way imagine
there's a ballot with ten issues on it
okay and I've got ten voice credits yeah
so if there's one issue that I would
like to vote twice on I have to spend
for voting credits on it okay and the
rule is that the number of voting hearts
you have to spend is the square of the
number of times you want to vote on yeah
yeah
so if I want to vote twice on an issue I
have to spend four of my tan on that if
I want to vote three times that I have
to spend nine right so for 16 5 2000
that goes fast that you up there fast
you want to vote 10 times that's a
hundred right credits yeah
yeah and but and but the reason this is
such an interesting idea is that it it
it it allows you to concentrate your
votes on the issues that you care most
about but it but it forces you to pay a
price for doing that yeah so it's
basically like you can think of it as
putting a cost on on like gsella tree
cell analysis and right now it's like
you know if I care about one issue so
much that I would that I want to you
know overwhelm the voices of other
issues overwhelm the voices of other
voters like if I want to like cause it
basically a counter majoritarian outcome
do i voting yeah I have to pay a cost
for that but what if I have the hundred
million dollars and I'm trying to put it
on like marketing for that for people to
get engaged on that vote then how would
that turn into
so square the hair well I mean that's
like something happening outside the
system right I mean if you're just if
you're using money to advertise for one
cause or another you yeah that's that's
outside of the ballot right I mean
that's outside of the ballot even in the
voting system that we have now right and
and it would it's likewise outside the
ballot care you know this is just kind
of this is like this is a better way of
doing a ballot but it doesn't solve the
problem of people you know circumventing
a ballot by for example putting a
billion dollars in marketing godlord
okay you know no but I'll make them pay
square for the marketing ya know right
of course yeah but but but but it raises
a super interesting philosophical point
which is that if you think about it the
power that you have in the political
system to vote you know and the power
that you have in the economic system to
you know put your money towards
advertising for something those are in a
way those are fungible with one another
right those are - those are basically
like two forms of political voice that
are operating different systems
according to a different set of rules
but they they're fungible with one
another they cross that boundary I mean
it creates interesting issues obviously
which what we're dealing with in our
politics now and then where is this
being implemented already and how is it
going so we were I mean one very
exciting thing that that happened is
that the the majority caucus in the
Colorado State Legislature used
quadratic voting to prioritize their
spending bills well so for example you
know so I'm probably getting the numbers
slightly wrong but I think it was like
they had 40 million dollar budget and
and a set of spending bills that would
have allocated 160 million dollars so
they had to like prioritize this they
had to decide you know which ones are
the most important yeah which ones are
we going to put out there and they they
used quadratic vote cool to decide among
themselves like you know which ones are
the most important and the
and what it did is it gave them it
actually I mean another great thing
about quadratic boiling if you compare
it to like regular voting is that it it
gives you more data because it doesn't
just tell you you know directionally
like where vote where each owner is
directions you houses Ellis they are
exactly should get it shows you strength
of preference yeah so you know you know
you want to you know back to what I was
saying before like you want to impose a
cost on on zealotry basically because
you you know it's not in principle it's
kind of a harm for you know one person
to try to outweigh the voices of other
people however in some cases you
actually want that you actually want to
allow that to happen in some cases
because for example sometimes a majority
oppresses a minority mm-hmm this is like
one of the classic problems of democracy
yeah and what what quadratic voting does
is it allows a little bit of a sort of a
safety valve for minorities to affect
counter majoritarian outcomes when they
care very strongly about a specific
issue they can all go really heavy on
that issue right but then if the
majority also goes really heavy on that
issue they'll still in that sense lose
right
but for it but at the margin it's it's
going to be a good thing when you know a
minority like resists you know at the
margin that safety valve is going to
avoid bad outcomes and here's why
because many cases of many cases of like
a majority oppression of the minority
have the future that the majority cares
more weakly than the minority about that
particular issue okay right so if you've
got like if you've got sixty percent of
a population you know who just you know
care is very weakly about a particular
issue but that particular issue causes
immense harm for the forty percent yeah
right you want that too you want the
forty percent to win and quadratic
voting gives me an avenue for that to
have yeah yeah
interesting yeah yeah I wonder if this
is like to be able to calibrate for
zealousness calculate for that is
something that's going to become really
popular in the next updates that we have
in our social fabric quadratic voting
it's an interesting concept yeah I mean
I think you want you want there you want
people to be able to express how
strongly they feel I mean that's that's
a really important piece of the
information that we should be able to
input into like a democratic process or
a collective decision-making process
it's really it's important for us be
able to represent our strength of
preference
you're like a weight amount of value to
like from a maybe from a zero to ten on
how much you care about this specific
issue yes what this yeah right but
there's got to be a cost per loss for
expressing a stronger preference because
otherwise everybody will just dial the
bow their preference I've detained on
everything yeah yeah yeah versus if you
do dial it up to ten you also have to
use more of your vote credits on that
yeah right yeah yeah which means you
have weaker voice on other issues yeah
yeah yeah and then everyone's just given
allocated a same amount of of credits
and that yeah yeah exactly which means
you know he can't buy more at the little
token booth no no and I mean then that
that's you can buy more marketing
dollars which is what we were talking
about right and buy more yeah right but
that's like you know that's a we're not
solving every problem at once yeah yeah
but the you know the fact that everybody
gets the same initial allocation of
credits is like
crucial obviously yeah because of course
yeah yeah okay let's let's do um
collective financing of public goods
okay and this is also another quadratic
finance yeah okay designing a matching
fund okay so this was this idea was it
has roots in older ideas but it it's
most recent you know I mean it's it's an
articulation in its current form what
happened in a paper that Glenn while
wrote with
Vitalik butyrin the founder of aetherium
and Zoe hit sig who's like an amazing
scholar from economists from Harvard and
the idea of quadratic finance quadric
finds kind of builds on some of the
ideas in quadratic voting and I guess
before I explain what that is
illustrating all again articulated in
words yeah so the way that the way the
quadratic fine it you can think of
quadratic finance as a better design for
matching funds like for example
philanthropic matching funds so the way
that if you think about the way that a
matching fund normally works it's like I
donate two dollars to the cause and then
the matcher matches it with two dollars
you donate $1 the cause mattre matches
it with $1 right so it's actually kind
of it's sort of like you know how do we
come up with that right it's sort of an
unsystematic system this is a this is a
way of designing that matching mechanism
in a way that is much better the way
that it works is you take the amount
that I donate to the cause the amount
that you donate the amount that
everybody else donates you take the you
take the amount this amounts that each
of us donate take the square root of
each of those amounts sum them all up
and then square that sum and which might
sound a little a little hard to process
a little obscure but it's actually
pretty mathematically simple there's not
too many things going on here you and
the and it has really really interesting
features the the the most the most
obvious upshot of this is that it means
that more matching funds are provided to
projects or proposals that have a
broader base of support okay and and and
this you gave we gave this example of
that if someone is one person's donating
nine percent of of a total amount of
money to store something versus if a
hundred people are donating nine percent
of a total amount of something then the
one that has a hundred people donating
nine percent will get more matching
exactly we're getting way more match way
more matching right yeah so so you just
want to again you want to kind of give
more to the one to one's two issues that
have more people backing them you want
to give more matched donations to
exactly versus ones that just have a
single really high pained person exactly
so if you've got only just like what if
you have one person backing an
initiative then there's no matching
funds at all right whereas if there's a
very broad group people who are all
donating small not so you have a large
man so this is I mean this what this
does is it illustrates the amount of
matching okay so let's say there's let's
say there are so these are different
voters or not voters but you know don't
donors also as what you just described X
X is what you described and there's only
one individual contribution there's no
matching yeah exactly so X so x y&z are
like proposals people are giving money
to you know they have you know a
matching guarantee you
the the five little things at the top
are people so the person on the Left
donates a big that big-block 2x and a
little bit to why a little bit to why
all right
the second person here donates like a
medium sized amount to why you know and
so on and so the proposal X you know if
you run it through that formula you know
you can see it gets no matching whereas
Y you know the you take the you know you
take the amounts that you know it got a
little bit from each person yeah you
stack them up that way and the the I'm
sorry got my hand in front of the thing
here but the the part with the squiggle
rep you can show that yeah yeah it's
totally part yes you know the area of
that squiggly part of the square
represents the amount of matching funds
that that proposal got yeah and you can
see that it's a greater amount because
it has this broader base of support
which just increases the size of that
Square where you know the the vacant
area is the matching amount yeah yeah
and then in Z there were two people that
supported cozy with larger contributions
right and so you know it has a it's it's
in between the two there's an
intermediate amount of matching relative
to the contributions that went into the
barracks place whereas Y has like a lot
more matching that came in because there
were five people but there were a less
individual contribution total amount of
like money in this case exactly
interesting and then can you give us an
idea of locations or quadratic financed
is already being used yeah so we get
coin for example used a used like a
slightly modified version of quadratic
financed to run a fundraising initiative
for various projects that you know you
know used to get coin platform to raise
money there's another block chain based
philanthropy
platform called we trust that
successfully ran a similar experiment
and so there are people out there you
know doing this and experimenting with
this but we have in mind much broader
kinds of applications for this kind of
thing like for example yes here the one
I think one really beautiful area where
quadratic finance could be used would be
like providing public funds to
journalism or something like that like
journalism is a great example because
it's like it's like a public good
you know everybody you've got good
journalism in a country or in the world
or whatever everything been is from
anything everything benefits from that
it makes the political system works
better it makes the economy work better
it just it has these like you know
non-excludable benefits that flow to the
entire society and you know so therefore
there should be some kind of like public
funding for it the problem is the
problem with public funding is that you
know who gets to make the decision about
where the public funds go right so
you've got like a government funding
journalism that can be that can be good
you know if you've got a government that
funds you know sounds journalistic
institutions like maybe the BBC or
something but then it can also be really
bad if you've got a government you know
pouring immense resources into like the
propagandistic state media and so it
creates this you know whenever you've
got public funds going towards
journalism it creates this question
about you know how do we like how is
that democratically accountable how do
we make sure that the government is
funding you know the right kind of
journalism if you imagine using
something like quadratic finance you
could you could you could imagine a
government providing the matching funds
here which would which would allow them
to like you know pour you know pump
money into
into journalism fun journalism but to do
so in a in a responsible way in a way
that's likely to serve the interests of
many as opposed to like the interests of
we know one trillionaire who you know
how to take your idea about which
newspaper is the best yes versus a
hundred thousand people that all want to
uplift and independent yeah paper
getting a lot of matching funding from
the government yeah exactly
and it's like you know the government's
not even picking the winner I mean the
government just has funds that it out
that it uses for yeah
matching period yeah and then it just
gets distributed based on the amount of
of of individuals that are contributing
towards specific outlets journalistic
outlets yeah bye-bye
amount of people not just by amount of
money exact one person yeah yeah and it
also encourages broad-based
participation you know in the like you
know the government would go out to
everybody and say okay we've got these
matching funds you know now so you know
don't get involved
now get involved put some money towards
the the journalistic outlets that you um
that you know you think are the most
important and even if I don't have much
money
I've still got a great incentive to
participate in that if the government's
using quadratic financing because my
small contribution is gonna get a much
bigger man - yeah then a billionaire
this also seems to help within the
politicians side of things as well where
a politician can get a billion dollars
of financing from a single individual
versus if they get a bunch of little $20
donations they can get a massive match
and then that politician has a greater
chance of representing the greater
amount of people than just one person
with an agenda yeah okay cool yeah okay
and then okay now last on the three we
have property common ownership
self-assess
taxation aka cost
okay yeah so actually I think there's
one other slide that has like a picture
of oh yeah let's do the yeah let's do
the guy first yeah yeah we'll do this
first
who's Henry George again so Henry
George's a he was a 19th century
American journalist and economist he was
kind of like a popular writer who had
sort of a bizarre unconventional career
but after working for journalism many
years or he wrote this book he wrote a
book in 1879 called
progress in poverty which which was like
immensely popular you know on according
to unconfirmed sources it was the
best-selling book in the English
language after the Bible for 30 years
after being published progress in
poverty tourism poverty so it's kind of
like wow he's kind of this like
surprisingly forgotten
nineteenth-century American popular
writer okay but he was also he gained
the respect of the entire economic
establishment through his ideas about
basically like the injustice of private
property in land so he's very
interesting ideas and what does the
unbounded Savannah so okay so he's got
in his book progress in poverty he
offers a thought experiment which i
think is quite beautiful and kind of
distills the essence of his contribution
to like the you know economics and
whatever and here's the thought
experiment so the the if you imagine if
you imagine like a theoretical abstract
expanse of land so and imagine that this
there's like a there's an expansive land
out there that extends to infinity in
every direction
whoa and it has no geographical or top
of graphical features and nobody lives
on just flat no one lives on in its
infinite it's just an infinite expanse
of feature
whistling okay alright not boring okay I
could all right and then imagine then
imagine one settler okay
strikes out onto that land looking for a
place to build a farm so the simulation
populates a single agent onto the
infinite exactly okay and they're making
a farm or we're thinking whatever me of
doing anything yeah and the but for the
sake of the thought experiment let's
didn't make the farm okay so somebody
goes to the out onto this expanse and
the thing to notice is that when this
person goes out looking for a place to
build a farm he or she is essentially
making a random choice it makes no
difference where he or she goes yeah
every every place every part of this
land is equally good it's infinite and
it's equally good it's equally good
because it has no future there's no part
with the river yeah right you know yeah
yes so it's all it's all exactly more
fertile land yeah okay okay so it's like
just throwing a dart for the second
agent comes then it's the same thing is
that you can just randomly plot anywhere
and it's the exact same level of
goodness yeah but hold on verse a so the
the first person goes out on this land
and builds a farm and so now imagine
this happening imagine the person going
out there building a farm he or she has
got to do everything they've got to
they've got to you know farm their own
crops build their own house make their
own shoes
Smith their own tools they've got to
everything got to be a
jack-of-all-trades
yeah and so maybe they can do it but
they're not gonna be like economically
rich they're gonna have to basically me
like cobbling together subsistence
living right now imagine a second person
coming today
to the expanse right so for the second
person the choice of where to go is not
the same as was for the first person
because the land is no longer unoccupied
and no longer featureless this second
person clearly you know it's clearly
most advantageous for this second person
to put down a farm in proximity to the
first
okay yes to a certain extent because
there's also the potential to go to the
exact opposite side of the land of that
person and then have the most far
distance from that person because if you
do want to expand your land potentially
just an idea
well it's also advantageous I don't go
next to the persons and there's another
human to engage with to trade with to
exact to all that I mean maybe you know
I'm skeptical that it's such a great
idea to go to the options yeah I think
you know if if the second person settles
close to the first person suddenly they
can trade right the treatment they can
they can transact the the one that's
better at farming can spend more time
farming know if there's a difference of
opinion then there's war that's well
that's that's true but just from an
economic richer okay that's from a
purely economic perspective they it's
economically advantageous for both of
them to live in proximity right and this
effect compounds so just you run that
run that you iterate that simulation
okay a million times and suddenly
instead of a couple subsistence farmers
you have like a thriving City and
they're specialists there's the ability
to be able to get rich exactly a
jack-of-all-trades all this type of
stuff exactly then the dynamics for
oligopolies and self-dealing in greece
and instead of the inclusive fitness of
treating people like a community right
yeah but the key thing to notice is that
once you've got a city there's me much
higher levels of like per capita wealth
being generated right guys they're all
trading you know they're all enjoying
you know take advantage of their you
know opportunity costs and competitive
advantage they get to do what they want
with their time yeah
unbounded savannah yeah it's a cool
thought experiment I like that one but
it's not over so here's the here's the
here's the next thing you notice about
thought experiment so once you've got
this city everybody's coming into this
city I'm making the city wealthier and
wealthier and wealthier the network
effect network effect yeah right but the
newcomers who keep coming to the city
and making it wealthier and wealthier
and wealthier may not be very well to
themselves the reason they may not be
very well themselves
in this thriving city somebody other
than them probably owns the land yeah
but they need to be on yeah create an
order to participate and that's the rent
seeking and that's their and that's and
so in the you know basically like the
value that they're adding to that
network is getting captured right up to
the margin literally in the form of rent
yeah yeah right literally the form of
just rent for their apartment whoever
okay so so this is the thing that Henry
George noticed and he was like well this
is a problem yeah this is an
inefficiency yeah you know huge
inefficiency yeah so so he had the idea
that billionaires profiting on dozens
and dozens of ownerships of pieces of
land meanwhile people that are trying to
contribute really good ideas or
organizations or memes or anything to
these areas when they come in fresh are
being sucked dry of all their resources
by rent-seeking behaviors of people that
are extremely wealthy in the first place
yeah for someone that just owns one hot
one home and just is trying to rent out
a room in that home right yeah that a
fair rate or whatever yeah right yeah
completely different so that's the
that's the that's the concept right
that's the thought experiment and so you
know Henry George's big idea which was
like super popular in the late 19th
century early 20th century and very
influential on a whole generation of
American like policy thinkers and
economists was basically the idea that
there's kind of that there's like this
distinction between what Henry George
would have called natural capital right
and artificial capital and so Henry
George wanted to put a tax on natural
capital essentially taxing away its
rental value right and not putting and
and then take away a lot of taxes reduce
all the taxes on artificial capital okay
so explain this more so artificial
capital is our met massive skyscrapers
megalithic structures the robots that
are okay made by labor yeah and the
natural capital is our beautiful
California coastline and mountains and
that's not made by labor right okay so
so natural capital now explain the taxes
again
so the idea is that is that the the
rental value that that can be gotten
from the ownership of natural capital
okay
ought to be taxed away I me text away
meaning well like like well his idea was
this again there should be a government
tax on you know land tax okay so he
wanted to and I should be clear that
like this is not this is not radical
exchanges idea this is like I'm just
kind of laying that you are laying yeah
you are yes yes so but this is the the
thought is that you know there should be
a tax on on land which Henry George
called the single tax and that that tax
on land should replace all kinds of
other to replace all the other taxes so
you know get rid of income taxes get rid
of taxes on you just down the other
thing okay and just like the only tax
there should be is on land would be on
way and why yeah and then what would you
do with natural capital versus
artificial capital taxing land
what do you re how would how would you
tax the land of natural capital versus
artificial capital so you'd figure out
the rental you'd figure out basically
the amount of money you could get
renting land and that would be your tax
come on money you could get rented the
amount the amount of money that an owner
could get from renting a piece of land
in a natural capital versus for natural
capital okay right and then tax away
exactly that amount so there'd be no you
know rent-seeking from ownership of
natural capital okay okay okay
so this is like okay this is Henry
George this is an you know yeah the
problem is if you think about like how
do you actually do that right how do you
actually figure out the the rental value
of land it's like you can't do it it's
not it's not like a practical idea that
can be implemented right but it has this
kind of theoretical yeah appeal yeah
that they captured the imagination of a
lot of people I like that simulation
that we just ran that was a really good
one yeah yeah like that and it
definitely too used us a lot about
network effects it teaches us a lot
about dynamics between people working
together to increase wealth but also
that can self deal I like that it's
basically a simulation of a civilization
how it evolves on a planet yeah right
yeah and what it does what what it what
it does is it it shows you that the
value of land like the value you know
that land has is it comes from a network
effect yeah it does the value of land
totally comes from a network of it and
that's not you know that's not once you
once you see that you can't unsee that
yeah but that's not obvious you know
what as you're going through your life
in 2019 it's not always obvious that you
know the reason this land and scepters
goes so valuable is because there's a
gigantic network effect tap happen it
involves people all around the whole Bay
Area who are engaging in transact
exchange and you know and and then
and that the ownership of this
particular land gives gives you the
ability to give you essentially
ownership over a slice of that network
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's well said
yeah we got to make those things that
are not so obvious more obvious for
people then we can push out the good the
good ideas so then is that how is that
part of the common ownership self-assess
taxation then so the common ownership
self-assess taxation is a way of its
kind of it you can think of it as like a
little update to Henry George it's it's
a it's a better way of doing what a more
flexible way of doing essentially what
Henry George wanted to do doesn't
necessarily have to apply to land and
it's not and I should be very clear that
like we're not we're not saying like oh
it's just like get rid of you know it's
not like a part of our policy agenda to
get rid of private property and land and
replace it with disorders it's just what
it is but it's a it's a way of thinking
about how to administer common property
yeah all right you know in other words
if you've got a if you've got a piece of
common property and you're thinking
about imposing a different kind of
property regime on it for example like
you might might take an expensive land
and say okay you know it's it's we're
gonna overlay a private property grid on
that pump on that common land now and
you know whoever goes mistakes their
private property claim first gets
private property right so that's like
you know you you could imagine like just
imposing a private property regime onto
a piece of common property or you could
imagine doing something different
something actually more efficient and
that's what the common ownership
self-assess taxation is getting at and
here's here's the idea so it's like
imagine you've got imagine you've got a
piece of land and there's a property tax
on the land
the the way the property taxes normally
work would be that some Assessor comes
and says what the land is worth and you
pay some percentage of that value that's
assessed by the Assessor so the way this
works is it instead you self declare
what you think the the land is worth now
obviously that creates an incentive to
self declare as low as possible that
catches that whatever you self declare
at the value to be you also have to be
willing to sell the to any buyer willing
to pay that amount so so it's not only a
self assessment it's also a sell offer
yeah right there's another kind of more
technical component to this which
involves you know how to think about the
exact level that the taxation rate
should be at within this but that is the
that is the basic idea and if you set
the tax at the right level you end up
with a situation where the what's called
the allocated efficiency gain will
outweigh the an investment efficiency
loss you end up with a with a system in
which land is which land or any other
analogous type of asset is being managed
more efficiently yeah right yeah yeah
the fiat feel like what you're
explaining to us with all of these is a
more just way to structure a society
that helps actualize more people's
fullest potential into the world ah I
love it
100% yeah that that's the that's the
idea and the you know so I mean one one
way that I think about institutions is
like
if you've got an institution you can you
can sort of evaluate it along launcher
different dimensions
what is backward-looking and what is
forward-looking mmm so you like if you
want to for example evaluate just or let
me give you an example in criminal
justice if you want to you know criminal
punishment is like an institution and
there are two different ways of
evaluating whether it's just they're two
different sort of classes of
justifications for criminal punishments
one is one is often called retributive
justifications the other is is sort of
like forward-looking justification so
utilitarian deterrence based
justifications incapacitation based
justification so in other words we've
got a punishment you can ask yourself
two kinds of questions about you can ask
does this punishment make sense in light
of the past action is it proportional to
the size of the crime right the other
question you could ask yourself is is
this punishment likely to lead to good
consequences going forward so a
forward-looking in backward-looking
justifications yeah right and the
backward looking justifications often
track the kinds of issues that we sort
of put under the heading of justice and
the forward-looking justifications track
the sorts of issues we put under the
heading of efficiency correct okay but
the I think that you can always learn
about one by looking at the other yeah
so in other in other words if like if
you if you think you've got this great
forward-looking justification for a
particular institution but it seems to
create this kind of like grotesque
situation when you when you look at it
for a backward-looking perspective
you're probably missing something even
from an efficiency perspective mm-hmm so
you know like an example of that would
be if you've got a
you know someone might come along and
say okay like if we punish speeding on
the road with the death penalty then
we'll save millions of lives right and
you might you know like you up blinkered
utilitarian might say oh that's a great
idea let's do it you know but then if
you look at it from this from a
backward-looking retributive perspective
it looks terrible because it's like
obviously you don't deserve the death
penalty
yeah for going five miles an hour over
the speed limit there's obviously a
mismatch there and that I had that
mismatch from the backward-looking
perspective tells us that we're missing
something when we when we conclude that
it's like an efficient forward-looking
yeah thing yeah so the justice and
efficiency both the married married in
institutional progress is so important
yeah exactly uh wolf this has been super
solid I've had a really good time
unpacking these subjects together Matt
let's ask you quick
arena simulation we don't have we Dec we
can't no I mean I'm sort of I wouldn't
say I'm persuaded but I'm open to the
arguments that we are and I don't think
it matters and then what do you thinks
the most beautiful thing in the world
Oh God
love and peace just you know yeah I mean
correctly interpreted both of those
things you know correctly interpreted
you know I I I think I want to live in a
world where
everybody thrives basically and I think
that everybody has a potential to to
thrive yeah and and I also want to live
in a world where people care about one
another care about themselves think
deeply about one another
think deeply about their relationship
with you know nature other species and
you know like I say
I've got a lot more to say about that
but it's not all you know coming out on
the tip of my tongue love and peace and
thriving for everyone yeah it's
beautiful
yeah yeah go with that I love it
Matt thanks so much for coming on the
show thank you it's a pleasure really
appreciate it thank you keep up the good
work
you too thank you thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on that
but so let us know should think and have
more conversations with your friends
your families co-workers people online
on social media about the topics that we
discussed here about what it's like to
have things like quadratic voting or
quadratic finance or how to best
structure a society and better one and
moving forward also check out the links
in the bio below to radical exchange org
as well as the Twitter for both our ad
exchange and format and also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
the scientists the indigenous elders
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow up them
flourish support simulation our links
are below or PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency if you want you can
design cool merch and get paid for it to
that link is below shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing thank
you very much Ronnie and go and build
the future everyone manifest those
dreams into the world we love you very
much thanks for tuning in we'll see you
soon
peace
[Music]